quel impact de la crise de kobe de 19
sur l'économie mondiale le fonds
monétaire international vient de rendre
son verdict et il n'est guère rassurant
après avoir touché l'économie réelle la
crise peut-elle se transmettre au
secteur bancaire déjà laminés en 2008
la contagion est elle inéluctable
peut-on encore éviter le pire on voit
tout cela tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir que l'on
retrouve aujourd'hui encore via skype un
bon jour jacques bienvenu bonjour
samantha alors jacques après la chute de
la production et l'explosion du chômage
la crise bancaire c'est ce qui nous
attend oui samantha c'est tout à fait ce
que l'on peut craindre le confinement
des principales économies provoque une
crise générale vous savez c'est un peu
l'extension du domaine de la crise en
référence au roman de michel houellebecq
alors cette crise touche plus ou moins
sévèrement toutes les économies et en
europe c'est la france qui apparaît le
pays le plus touché
mais cette crise ne se propage pas
seulement de pays en pays elles frappent
désormais tous les secteurs et après la
chute de la production dont on a déjà
parlé après la crise pétrolière que l'on
a évoqué sur rtl il ya de ça quelques
quelques semaines après la montée du
chômage ce sont donc les banques qui
sont aujourd'hui touchées et comme on
peut l'imaginer si les banques sont
aujourd'hui malades
et bien c'est bien parce que l'économie
réelle va mal alors jacques il faut
peut-être commencer par cela les les
banques pourquoi les banques souffrent
hôtel alors que cette crise n'est pas
née de la sphère financière
oui vous avez tout à fait raison c'est
non 1 samantha
mais c'est en réalité très logique
l'ampleur de la crise et d'aujourd'hui
tels qu'une partie des dettes des
entreprises aux banques ne seront pas
remboursés alors le mécanisme est hélas
très simple avec le confinement les
entreprises du moins pour les plus
nombreuses ont vu leur chiffre
d'affaires s'effondrer
et comme elle ne rentre pas d'argent
elles ne peuvent plus donc payer que ce
soit le principal où les intérêts de
leur emprunt
cela constitue d'ailleurs dans les
bilans bancaires ce qu'on appelle dans
le jargon technique de la profession
l'énorme performing loans où les
créances douteuses en bon français
de tels engagements les banques en ont
toujours mais il ne représentait jusque
là que 2 5% à 2 que de 0 5% à 2% de
leurs prêts or du fait de la crise
on s'attend à ce qu'il atteigne les 30 %
voire plus et c'est bien ce qui explique
aujourd'hui que le cours en bourse des
principales banques seraient en train de
s'effondrer alors que ce soit bnp
paribas la société générale ou le crédit
agricole qui commence d'ailleurs à
provisionner ou encore les grandes
banques italiennes ou allemandes qui
elles aussi vont provisionner le risque
lié aux que vides 19 alors on danse pour
revenir justement à cette idée jacques
puisqu'on parlait des banques est ce
qu'on n'est pas
on est dans le scénario inverse
aujourd'hui de 2008
est ce que c'est le secteur réel qui
contamine aujourd'hui le secteur
bancaire absolument samantha vous avez
tout à fait raison c'est l'ampleur de la
crise dont le secteur réel crise qui est
induite directement par le confinement
duo kobe 19 qui provoque cette situation
car c'est bien d'une crise généralisée
dont il faut parler alors si l'on en
croit les données du fonds monétaire
international pour la première fois
depuis 1945
le pib mondial va reculer de 3%
on le voit la plupart des pays
industrialisés mais aussi de nombreux
pays en développement vont connaître de
très fortes baisses de croissance
justement dans les estimations du fmi s
qui a pas une forme d' exagération à
jacques
hélas non on pourrait le souhaiter mais
ce n'est pas le cas on peut même penser
que les estimations du fmi pêche encore
par optimisme pour l'europe
le recul sera supérieur par exemple à 10
% pour la france mais aussi en italie et
en espagne
globalement la perte de richesse
engendrée par le passage d'une
croissance qui était prévu avant
l'épidémie à + 3 % et qui aujourd'hui
est annoncé en recul de -3%
et bien cette destruction de richesse va
atteindre pratiquement les 10 trillions
autrement dit les dix mille milliards de
dollars pour 2020 tous les pays vont
être touchés jacques will samantha mais
certains plus que d'autres c'est ce que
l'on remarque d'ailleurs sur la carte
cas produite le fmi la chine le 6 mai
denaisis et un certain nombre de pays
d'afrique comme le kenya le mozambique
où le sénégal devrait peut-être moins
souffrir que le reste du monde
alors cette crise et c'est aussi une
chose importante va accélérer le
pivotement d'une économie mondiale qui
était centré sur l' axe etats unis
europe vers une économie qui sera
désormais largement basé sur le
dynamisme des pays émergents et de
l'asie
parmi les graves conséquences auxquelles
il faut s'attendre jacques ce qu'il faut
craindre le retour de l'inflation voire
de l'hyperinflation alors ce n'est pas
et de loin le scénario le plus probable
en réalité l'inflation devrait être très
modérée alors toujours d'après les
estimations du fonds monétaire
international l'inflation restera
globalement faible entre 0 et 2% en
europe et aux états unis autour de 3% en
chine en inde et en russie
pourquoi cela alors que les banques
centrales d'ailleurs injecte massivement
de la monnaie injecté massivement des
liquidités dans l'économie
et bien parce que la demande va rester
faible dans de très nombreux secteurs
alors ça n'exclut pas que certains
produits en particulier pour certains
produits alimentaires pourrait connaître
des hausses de 4 à 10%
ce qu'on peut constater d'ailleurs quand
on va faire ses courses mais globalement
les autres prix vont stagner voire
baisser et l'impact sur les finances
publiques est ce que ce sera important
oui samantha c'est évident là encore le
fonds monétaire international s'attend à
une forte hausse des déficits
budgétaires dans le monde comme on peut
le voir plus les pays seront
industrialisées et développé d'ailleurs
et plus leur déficit sera important
comme dans la france il proviendra à la
fois de l'accroissement des dépenses
fait pour éviter un effondrement total
des économies sous confinement et de la
contraction d'ailleurs des recettes
publiques du fait même de cette crise
alors à l'échelle mondiale
c'est un besoin de financement de 11 %
du pib mondial qu'il faut s'attendre ce
besoin ne pourra être financé il faut le
dire clairement que par les banques
centrales
or dans la zone euro la récente décision
la décision du 5 mai du tribunal
constitutionnel de karlsruhe risque très
fortement de limiter les moyens de la
banque centrale européenne de faire cela
évidemment avec la hausse du déficit
public
il faut s'attendre aussi à une hausse de
la dette publique jacques c'est cela oui
oui oui ça c'est évident on va assister
à une hausse sensible à la fois parce
que le montant des dettes var augmenté
avec la montée des déficits publics mais
aussi parce que le pib va baisser
il y aura donc une hausse mécanique du
ratio dette sur pib
un ratio qui devrait atteindre pour
l'ensemble du monde
122 % et on voit bien ici encore dans
les données qui ont été produites par le
fonds monétaire international les
différents seront importantes par
exemple 250 % pour le japon 131 % pour
les etats-unis est globalement
l'amérique du nord
entre 115 et 122 % pour la france et
l'italie mais seulement 65% pour la
chine voire même 18% c'est très très
très faible pour la russie des chiffres
impressionnants est ce que c'est une
crise mondiale hors du commun finalement
qui nous attend oui tout à fait samantha
tout à fait c'est une crise mondiale
d'une ampleur telle qu'il faudra que les
gouvernements prennent leurs
responsabilités et qu'ils assument par
exemple le contrôle des banques qui sont
très affaiblis qu'ils acceptent la
monétisation directe de leurs déficits
par les banques centrales
en d'autres termes cette crise va mettre
en évidence les principes mêmes de ce
qu'on appelle la souveraineté économique
et monétaire merci beaucoup jacques
sapir pour ses explications une analyse
très
liste de l'ampleur et des conséquences
économiques à venir de cette crise à
très bientôt jacques sapir sur arte
france
merci à vous samantha